هذه هي الطريقة التي تقطع
بها مظاهر العديد من
السبل اللانهائية للفساد البائس في
لبنان ، فإن
ما يُنظر إليه على أنه حكم الأقلية السياسية
قد
أفرغ البلد بأكمله من الداخل على مدى عقود
في سلسلة لا نهاية لها
ومتفاقمة باستمرار من
الخلل
الوظيفي والسرقة.  في يوم الثلاثاء
الرابع من أغسطس
في وقت مبكر من المساء ، رأينا
المثال الأكثر روعة على ذلك حيث تم تدمير جزء كبير
من المدينة
في انفجار على عكس أي انفجار لم
يسبق له مثيل ، وبقي الكثيرون يتساءلون
لماذا تم تخزين نترات الأمونيوم
في الميناء وكم من الوقت  هل كان هناك من كان
يعلم عنها وعن مخاطرها ومن
يغض الطرف عن هذا رغم أنه مجرد
أحدث وأوضح مثال على
نظام أوسع بكثير من الخلل الوظيفي حيث
فشلت الحكومة بعد الحكومة في لبنان في القيام
بوظيفتها الأساسية ورعاية
شعبها  أساسي وأعني أن الخدمات الأساسية
خاطئة بسبب انقطاع الكهرباء على
مدار
اليوم وتذكر هذا النهر من القمامة
لم يكن هناك أحد من أجله  لقد استمر الأمر
واستمر في الحرارة بشكل جيد ، ماذا عن
حرائق الغابات المتفشية التي اندلعت في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
العام الماضي لم تتم صيانة طائرات الهليكوبتر
وبالتالي
لم يتمكنوا من الوصول إلى أسفل
كل ذلك ،
شخص ما  يملأون جيوبهم على
حساب شخص آخر وفوق كل
ذلك كارثة اقتصادية
بطالة هائلة وفقدان العملة اللبنانية
60 في المائة من قيمتها في أقل
من
عام ، كما أن لديها ثالث أكبر
نسبة دين إلى إجمالي الناتج المحلي ، لذا استمع إلى  هذه
[الموسيقى]
كنت هناك في بيروت في أواخر العام الماضي
عندما كانت هذه المكالمات ترن
في الشوارع
[تصفيق]
الجميع يعني الجميع حيث
طالب المتظاهرون الحكومة
بالخروج وما لم يغير شيئًا جيدًا
ربما في الحقيقة بعض الوجوه غير
النظام المنقسمة  لبنان أنهم
الآن جزء من
نسيج البلد لا يزالون كما هو ، فنحن
الآن بعد حوالي 30 عامًا من
الحرب الأهلية اللبنانية ويبدو الأمر
سيئًا كما كان دائمًا ولماذا
حقًا لماذا  الآن بيروت تزينها ذات مرة
بينما
باريس الشرق الأوسط التي تقع
بين المياه الزبرجدية للبحر
الأبيض المتوسط
ال مونت لبنان المذهلة التي تجلس مد
رة ومدمرة عل
نطاق لا يزال غير مفهوم ، مر
أخرى ، لم يكن هذا الانفجار حتميًا ، و
م تكن الأزمة الاقتصادية حت
ية  ولا انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ولا الافتقار إلى الوظائف
والأنظمة الأساسية
عبر الطيف السياسي في لبنان ،
تسود أيديولوجية واحدة ما بداخلها
وما يتبقى للناس في
كثير من الأحيان سوى اليأس
منك